les professeurs me disent que vous ne
participerez pas aux cours que vous avez commencé
à porter des pyjamas tous les jours
comprenez-vous de mon point de vue comment ces
choses peuvent être classées comme des drapeaux rouges
ils sont juste à l'aise avec moi quoi de neuf
avec toi Champa don  ne m'appelle pas alors tu
penses que toi et ta femme vous allez
divorcer juste une bagarre Je merde tout le
temps parce que c'est ce que font les gens la
vie est un gâchis nous faisons tous de
notre
mieux oncle James up  Et
où en étions-nous,
tu es en colère contre moi à propos de mes
retards, non, écoute, tu veux un bal au centre commercial